comes off to the Rossum  for the half here's a four-track of the  night tomorrow we're gonna expect this  all the time now everybody on - frozen -  rozer now to wipe this off I mean he  throws it down on the entire stadium  everybody got up out of there one of  their seats to see that in that term and  that comes along with the Spurs  improvement defensively oh no - Marge  erosion welcome back to SoCal demar  derozan beautiful spin move on Tobias  Harris and then puts Gallinari on his  basketball poster how about this right  here almost turns his back on the  defense  [Music]  [Applause]  - power - Rosen DeRozan will jackhammer  this one in further screws  [Applause]  [Music]  the time  15 and 9 for yolk its Spurs with a ball  under two minutes of rosin got a  freerunning closing down two-handed Jam  what's up you guys this Taylor Brooks  with Bleacher Report make sure that you  subscribe for some more video content